pronto si sentite allora scrivete csc
sentite perché non sappiamo se funziona
tutto qualcuno ci sente si sentite
potete consumi
grazie per gli auguri scrivete esserci
sentite perché quindi si sa ma ci vedete
allora però vi ci prendiamo ok sto
cercando di 20 artisti va bene comunque
grazie per gli auguri davvero grazie
mille
anche se sicuri che se ne sono liberati
senza che è successo niente tirare il
gruppo che avete scritto su internet è
ok vedo che state scrivendo tutti sì sì
sì davvero male abbiamo visto marchi
tagliate 3 produzione debutto comunque
di assaggiarla lo sapevamo
quindi non vedevamo l'ora di iter e la
live per saltare questa torta prima però
ovviamente studiamo le devi decidere
perché è così il primo desiderio
ovviamente non mi sarei aspettato che il
mio compleanno sarebbe finito poi in
quarantena
ma purtroppo questa è la situazione anzi
mi dispiace perché un sacco di gol mi
hanno scritto che anche voi avete
passato il problema dei 40 casi un sacco
però ricordatevi sempre che si può ri
festeggiare dopo molto bene
allora praticamente qua e un po troppo
per non far niente delle quasi che sia
buona iniziamo oggi sono legato da un po
così che una mia grande paura e il fuoco
perché appunto delle fortissime
esperienze giornale raccolto ma non ora
perché teniamo il governo allegro in
tantissimi visto di dire quanti anni
convive dio che ci ha compreso le
camicie qua non ci riesce e chi scrive
vincolo giusto nella chat
vediamo un po che dopo mi svegliavo una
cosa un segreto
allora io tra l'altro da un sacco di
anni che non festeggio il compleanno
proprio con l'altro alta e le candeline
in realtà quest'anno hanno deciso che lo
avremmo festeggiato ma ironia della
sorte siamo ovviamente allora infatti
state scrivete i numeri delle carte di
22 25 27
oddio 10
si tratta allora fitta sia una cosa
importante
ho visto i gufi qualche tipo prima di
esprimere
quale tradizione si dice un desiderio
così alta è 1 1
il mio desiderio prima di soffiare e che
tutto torni alla normalità presto
possibile l'altro 3 adesso sarà facile
comprare il pane vino perché eletto di
ama e lo dico come quelle piccole
preoccupate perché non so che se no me
la chiedereste ovunque si integra
inizialmente tradizionalmente resistenza
non si devono spezzare le candele avevo
sentito questa tradizione che si usavano
nomi che modo di spezzare dai dicono che
si porta fortuna così fiume in
tantissimi state scrivendo vecchi 25 27
24 14
grazie grazie grazie allora vi dico il
numero esatto perché so che lo
scriverete continuano i bus e compie 27
anni come me ti cerca di celare un
progetto di porta senza candelina
pregando
inter in realtà le candeline erano meno
soddisfatto perché la posizione ma vabbè
dai un bagnetto dai allora tagliato
perché sanno posso fallire le torte tra
l'altro attacco di cuore
e ancora per difficile così quando
avrebbe fatto pure con cui i commenti
perdiamo ma c'è riceviamo e no che non
la mangiano che facciamo anche un po di
ma ben nove perché poi vi facciamo
vedere dei regali alcuni auto regalini
che lo faccia se i regali che mi opzioni
tale visto che stesse sempre super
curiosi per queste cose dobbiamo tutti
quanti
poi me li possono vedere quindi restate
online allora state continuato a
scrivere le tasse o essere la torta
tonalità e questa giordania allora si
chiama così la vedono bene anche loro se
la cremo al centro che stai facendo voi
controllate lo è laico non ti controlla
e potrebbe anche sparire con la torta da
un momento all'altro perché faccio io
sono distratta leggere commenti che
grazie video possiamo pure io scrivevo
in tantissimi rimangiare cucina un
pochino di più così leggiamo meglio
convinto perché non sapete che io sono
diventata cieca
io davvero più niente
[Applauso]
sicuramente però sanno scrivere la vita
ripresa
il più grande brera uno stentato ma
adesso probabilmente lo stesso momento
ma bang o un bookmark c'è chi lo chiama
book bank
vediamo un po io non diro peste nera
sulla buona anzi no non hai ragione
ragione non è buono mantello di monza si
si sente primo cane non è campato per
caso un modo comodo veduta no da pd e
quella sarà la mia colazione non
mangiate a allora curiosi di sapere che
cosa tutto state scrivendoli 28
scommetto che la vi facciamo venire fame
una buona allora è difficile dei
commenti perché vanno sono velocissimi
fatte e siamo lontani buonissimo grazie
amore purissima prego tanti auguri o
compleanno andrea va bene allora
felicissimo di fare la torta so perché
state fatte poi sarebbe mancato il primo
mi limiterò anche trovato un po
aggiustato agendo di bello vediamo se
riusciamo a leggere qualcosa come state
passando questa quarantena
chiacchieriamo un po
diteci come state ri manca la scuola
come la state passando grazie contenute
barbetta con gli auguri grazie
ora mi fa venire
ma noi e mangiare tutto non abbiamo
preso portato da bere è sempre così del
limone limo rosa il latte alla crema al
limone
sarebbe bello se commesso io in sagra
non ci si potesse connettere con
qualcuno e parlarvi prettamente poverini
perché se non mi seguite anche artisti
andremo ad avvertirmi che magari farò
qualche live di cui parliamo bene per
tutte le i limoni
diteci voi aveste fatto colazione
merenda avete fatto merenda avete fatto
merenda che se lo possono venire a me
oltre all altro possiamo raccontare di
qualche spoiler di tale da spingere la
mia era più piccola ma ne parliamo un
attimino di cose serie perché siccome
italy e quindi basta tutti l'hanno visto
tutti
io ho già dato la fetta più grande per
me e mi son preso la fetta più piccola
non ha mai non ci sara piu piccola 2 la
fuga te tu continui a parlare io stavo a
mangiare come modererà programma
facciamo qualche spoiler solo per voi
ok anteprima il live i quali saranno i
prossimi video non ditelo a tutti
dietro tutti gli altri abbiamo già
registrato bit e raccontate migliore
quello dal compleanno non l'abbiamo
fatto
bene se si rompe tutto è ok vediamo un
po parlati lo sbaglio di video minuti
partire un sacco evitiamo natale
abbastanza nostro caso della
fastidiosissima stiamo morendo
tantissimo e la fastidiosissimo loro
però è stato super divertente e molto
era molto molto molto molto divertente
non compriamo centro centro non
compleanno dai quindi un 80 devo devo
ancora invitarlo lo farà domani si
potrebbe uscire domani sera dai che
l'idea c'è un matto 12 6 perse vitale
normale che è rimasto però arriva
abbinare i commenti qui non li vedo se
qualcuno già capito un continuo dagli
auguri grazie grazie mille
non completando un reato se non
compleanno un matto l'orologio c'è c'è
per te vediamo se qualcuno indovinando
scrive una sola gioco il no
c'è un cappellaio matto matto quindi
potrebbe essere questa potrebbe essere
il tema è uno dei voti video preferiti
in assoluto quindi da qui potete già
capire cosa fare se non lo scrivo
nessuno ma chissà cosa che capita subito
bravissimi alice nel paese delle
meraviglie monumenti ma quello che fa
per dire evitare se volete vederlo da
cappellaio partner e mario matt è un
posto bellissimo tantissimo domani
mattina i tubi di potrebbe andare a noi
le persone due a due e mezzo forse
lettera ci sto a fare il tempo ci hanno
messo le multi del colletto bianco che
per aver venduto subito sì ma super
intelligenti e mira standogli vicino ha
realizzato i compensi storica allora
però questo video non so quando andrà
online perché non siamo solo noi lo
stiamo realizzando
non un po dice vabbè dai racconta
racconta tutto tv sulla torta ma dovevo
dire tutto tutto grazie allora è un
video particolare e all'esterno e
all'interno facendo rinata e a quadri
non è un video interattivo
infatti vediamo sempre questo ne
indovinano continuano a vedere che
ancora non in codice sm avete portato
indici sono così tosca piceno to be to
be funghi pasta dico altro ci stiamo
avvicinando
vediamo se indovinate quindi avrei
capito la gli indizi mentre provando
ordinare tubi lunghi sms sono le
iniziali vediamo qualcuno indovina
vitale e sipro manoscritto 9.40 e fatto
affari scritto veder emergere incubo per
capire visto che è proprio subito viene
subito basta curare come si può capire
infatti stata indovinando quindi si si
si
a grandissima richiesta torna supermario
però in modo incredibile e bellissimo
bellissimo l'altra volta abbiamo fatto
questa volta è completamente diverso
perché entrare però che sarà aprile sono
delle cose molto particolari destro per
quello che non lo stiamo facendo solo
noi ma mio fratello più il suo collega
che fanno animazione in 3d
mia serie a gli scopi costretti cosa
sono bravissimi quindi sono loro che
stanno gestendo la parte più complicata
è ben altro vedremo una cosa
spettacolare veramente allora era
appunto hanno bisogno di un po più di
tempo per realizzarla so che voi perché
ci abbiamo qualche altro spoiler
preparato una step rom romeni che ben
parlare ancora a me è perché già parlato
ancora di rubate allora che ho al
momento altri spoglia forse no vediamo
io volevo prendere qualche domanda
la mia scrivetemi sta sforzando dalla
troppo vediamo vediamo l'ora di vedere
queste questi due video soprattutto
quello quello del cappellaio matto se
sicuro mi piacerà un sacco ma ovviamente
è ovviamente anche quello quello di
supermario stessi ok ok allora
supermario funghetti vedevo in ottica
ombra dello speciale male allora berlino
marino a qui non ci arrivano dal pro
alcol divertendo un sacco berlino tra
l'altro perché con queste belle giornate
davvero qui di sole lui sta godendo
tantissimo si mette proprio al sole e
bel tempo adesso per contento allora ma
stiamo in regali adesso sembra un'idea
psi ogni cosa che io farò vedere voi
dovrete dare un voto nella top quindi
preparatevi a dare i voti da 1 a 10
così vediamo qual è quello che nel voto
più alto con la dotta i dragoni e mezzo
perché ora di crema
e comunque una postazione di certo
quindi preparatevi al tar i voti da 1 a
10 per ogni cosa e poi alla fine potrete
sedersi con e ferite quattro come se non
ti avessi visto allora iniziamo dalle
cose più bella la scatola è la cosa più
noiosa e cioè una lente per la rara per
fare il litio ma 6 mm non penso che
interesserà le strutture per noi troppo
perché si vedono ancora meglio poi io
sono ancora più belli ma come questa
live registrato a scendere tanto inizia
a guardare i voti ma pensieri si siano
alla torta
eh sì perché non penso che per la lente
allora hanno dato un voto 6 o di
ristoranti pub e navette dai forti poi
passiamo dopo i dati di troppo ma stiamo
sempre il teatrino allora questo che non
ho montato ancora non ho avuto posto che
fu di stato di cose è un teatrino da
mettere sul tavolo praticamente da
bruciare
ecco teatrino perciò mi discosto
si starà indotto il video arrivato cioè
uno particolare per altri è in cantiere
ed è una storia super pazzesco perché
tra qualche settimana con sé 12
settimane uscirà anche una nuova serie
nel canale è piuttosto sfoderare ancora
perché ho deciso sulla storia ci sarà un
in proprietà viziosa bellissimo magari
ve la farò bene vediamo contagia i
vostri 10 98 5495 che ci quindi questo è
piaciuto di più del 20 di media dai
ghisa robert perche no poi non si
capisce dalla webcam bordo praticamente
la luna e cioè praticamente si chiamerà
luna collaborazione tra forma di luna e
che prima di accendere scaricata in
siria questo dovrebbe essere una
italiano svolgere tipo stesse scriveva
usa dopo che facebook è chiaro che la
faccio per traverso ma sotto carica che
lo facciamo vedere noi comunque
praticamente si abbassa telecomando si
può scegliere il colore della
è passato così cambia colore e portati
al e scaricato tu che sei stato tante
volte poi adesso può contare ovviamente
tom cuise questo progetto ha pure
portato in giro cosa fantastica che non
si attacca alla presa quindi si può
ricaricare però senza fili io adoro
perché odio i figli non so perché ma
sono fissata con infatti o il mouse
senza fili
la tastiera media mica comunque che voto
date però avete visto come è fatta un
sacco di dieci è piaciuto tantissimo
porto 97 10 degli 8 10 allora che cosa
rimane il cennato qui è un po difficile
da scrivere questa perché il re
soprattutto con chi si sa né perché su
questo era questa la tazza di tisana me
questa è la tappa e dentro sia l'altro
cosina da mettere il filtro e metti
dentro i cosiddetti cani e canti sono
spiegato male
ottimo hanno capito tutti molto 11
addirittura poi alle più grande che
forse sentito dire che non se ne sono
accorti
allora l'altro è la cosa più grande è
una cosa che io volevo tappa di tempo
quindi mi sono regalata questa cosa ok
si è questo nuovo e vedere solo una
scusa
allora arrivare uno scherzo fino all'oro
anche questo è un auto pregarlo allora
praticamente questo è un quadretto di
stringer pensa che è una deve essere
preferite in assoluto però ha qualcosa
di particolare questo quadretto perché
non so se riusciti a vederlo poi e
sembra tridimensionale infatti se
guardasse loro grande sembra che si
spostano e poi in base a dove lo guardi
si vede il cielo o blu o rosso con il
mais thrier ora quindi il relatore un
sacco perché a dovere di voto 67 questo
bene vedo che vi piace questa volta
destinato a coprire così io vado a
prendere compriamo nei commenti
nella chat se non vedete più grosso
rischio vedere la cosa tridimensionale
[Risate]
sacco e ha deciso di regalarmi la realtà
volevo prendere un altro ma non quello
perché però regalo
praticamente è il cappello si copre
grazie e il castello disney
leggo finalmente sento castello
apparteneva ad abitare a castello leggo
quello di disneyworld se non vuole un pò
triste non è l'odore è bellissimo
in realtà io volevo prendere cappello di
harry potter perché io sono una
grandissimo appassionato di harry potter
da fabbro piccolo
voto 10 però hai ottenuto il reporter la
tipo il doppio più grande e aveva un
sacco di pezzi ed era proprio per
esperti da onorare noi già non abbiamo
mai montato leggo cioè io molto con le
due quando ero piccola neanche uno
quindi ancora non sapevamo se saremmo
riusciti a montarli questo tempo questo
tipo 4000 pezzi cristo che il livello di
esperienza dice feliz charlie quindi
forse ce la facciamo siamo dietro così
veneti è stata altissimo
questo è il castello come dentro come
come sarà una cosa che votiamo quindi
per quello ho deciso di non prendere il
castello di harry potter ha ancora
magari prima vediamo come si troviamo
facevamo noi ci mettiamo due mesi a saro
non possiamo se ci riusciamo magari un
giorno prendono quello di harry potter
comunque subito della santa in dieci che
voto date al castello leggo limoni e non
vedo l'ora di montarlo perché comunque
anche rilassante muntari lei quindi
questo era l'ultimo regalo
stiamo in lei gioca già mezz'ora
succede tutto il tempo
io sto tipo perdendo la foto che
dimostrano bisogna parlare per mezz'ora
di fila come sono super contento perché
è troppo bello né servi in diretta
pacchetto che non vi possiamo vedere in
diretta però a notte poi noi con un
tacco di limoni ovviamente ma anche
furio si è sentito i fondi altro mezzo
ha dato i conti gli piaciuto un patto il
castello continuerà il coni marche
perché deve sapere che io li adoro i
fondi così e così a me piace un sacco
vi piacciono tutte le persone proprio
per doriana però talmente tanti funghi
ho fatto con la zuppa di funghi ricordo
una capanna di punti e curato da
concerto saranno troppo 40 funghi zuppa
dottoressa purissima ben sei un
cucchiaio di questo che quindi ci siamo
divertiti taking con voi
ricordatevi che vi vogliamo veramente
tanto tanto bene
leggiamo sempre i vostri commenti ci
divertiamo tanto di sale uovo lei siamo
proprio una super femminili siamo super
contenti veramente e magari faremo
qualche altro live in questi giorni
visto che siamo tutti a casa ovviamente
mi racconta un amore poi caricata e se
volete potete rivedere sa mai perché la
salderò da pubblicherò nel canale quindi
quando volete potete rivederla e poi ora
vi mostriamo limone e qualche affondo 20
limone fisso dopo persone e musiche
piangevano però è troppo perdendo la
voce io ribattei qua tutto il giorno e
altri niente allora vi ricorda che
domani ci sarà il video trova sly
un'astuzia dal cappellaio matto che
vitale film ora troppo ridere comico
attivate la compone lina poi prezzo si
sarà super mario
poi esiste leone skyroom qui voglio
sperare troppo
poi ci sarà un segreto è finito non
essere fantastica non vedo
ora quindi campanella attiva e noi vi
salutiamo e mandiamo conduzione loro
grazie
si fa fatica col neo aver festeggiato il
mio compleanno assieme grazie mille per
tutti gli auguri e niente ci vediamo
domani con il mondo invidio ora pubblico
questa lei forse capisco come si fa a
degli attivi
[Applauso]